we've talked about the idea of average
total cost in several videos so far
where it was the sum of your average
variable cost and your average fixed
cost but when we're talking about fixed
costs by definition that means we're
talking about things in the short run
remember the short run is defined as the
amount of time over which at least one
of your inputs is fixed but if we talk
about longer term so let's say you're
running a factory and in the short run
the short run would be how long it takes
to build another factor or how long it
takes to close down or sell another
factory but in the long run you can
always add more factories or shut down
factories so in the long run everything
is variable so what we're going to do in
this video is think about how the
average total cost that we've studied in
previous videos which were actually
short run average total costs how those
relate to the long run average total
cost
so let's imagine that we are trying to
open up a food truck business
and let's say that each food truck
so each food truck and let's say we're
going to sell tacos so these are taco
food trucks
and so each food truck can optimally
optimally i'll just write like that
serve
serve 100 tacos
per
day
and we haven't started our business yet
but we have to decide how many food
trucks to buy and we do some market
research and we feel pretty confident
that we're going to be able to sell 200
tacos to per day
so we're going to target
target 200
tacos
tacos per day
now in this world what you would want to
do is optimize your fixed cost to
minimize your average total cost for 200
tacos per day remember your fixed cost
is essentially going to be let's say
it's just your food truck and then
you're going to have a variable cost it
might be the staff that's that's making
the tacos it might be the supplies for
the tacos things like that
and so you might have an average total
cost curve that looks like this
so let me make some axes here
so
this is going to be quantity of tacos
per day
quantity
of tacos
this is going to be per
day
and then in the vertical axis this is
going to be cost per taco
cost
per taco
and let's say since you're optimizing
for 200 tacos today you want to minimize
your cost per taco 200 tacos per day
that happens with two food trucks
so
if we're at 200 tacos per day let me put
it right over there 200 tacos per day
we get to a cost per taco average total
cost per taco
let's say that is 50 cents
so that is 50 cents right over there but
the actual number of sales the actual
number of tacos that you might have to
produce in a given day might vary from
that and that will actually help
construct your average total cost curve
and so your average total cost curve
might look something like this
it might look
might look something
like this we've seen curves like this in
the past and we would call this our
average total cost but now because we're
differentiating between our short run
and long run let's make this very clear
this is our short run
average total cost and this is a
situation where we have two
of our food trucks
per day to food trucks
now what if instead of 200 tacos per day
it ends up that we only have to produce
100 tacos per day because that's how
many people are demanding so let's say
this is 100 right over here well if we
keep our the number of trucks we have
constant so we don't change our fixed
costs well then our cost per taco is
going to be higher let's say that this
right over here is let's say this is 70
cents
70 cents
per taco
and then there's the other scenario
let's say that our tacos sell better
than expected let's say that we need to
somehow produce 300 tacos per day well
if we can't change our fixed costs which
is by definition what the short run is
well then we might be at say this point
looks like it would be about let's just
call that 80 cents
80 cents
per taco as our short run average total
cost
now in either of these situations let's
say that
we have the more pessimistic scenario
actually happens that there's only
demand for a hundred tacos per day well
in that world the rational thing would
be hey let's sell one of those trucks
we're only at 50 utilization at 100
tacos per day let's sell one of those
trucks to lower our average total cost
and so in the long run you can adjust
your fixed cost so with one truck
we're at a curve that looks like this so
at 100
100 tacos per day
our costs
are 60 cents per taco
and the curve might look something like
something like this so if things were to
get even worse than that our cost would
go up and if for some reason the market
were to actually go back to what we
expected or even beyond then our cost
would go even higher so this cost curve
which is based on one truck so let me
call this our short run
average total cost and this is for one
truck
this would be sub-optimal if we actually
do have 200 sold 200 units being
produced today or 300 units produced per
day but it is optimal for 100 units per
day
now things could go the other way you
might start with those two trucks that
are optimal for 200 units per day 200
tacos per day but you're in the world
where people want to buy 300 tacos per
day and 300 tacos with two trucks is not
optimal so in the long run you order
another truck and maybe it takes a
couple of months for it to show up and
be outfitted whatever but once you get
that third truck now you can optimally
serve 300 tacos per day
and so
you might be in this situation
so
at if you get another truck you could
have another short run average total
cost curve that looks something
like this right over here so this is our
short run
average total cost curve and so this is
when we have three
trucks and remember the short run is
when at least one of your inputs is
fixed and in this one for the simplified
model we're assuming that input is the
truck that everything else is a variable
expense
now when you look at this it helps us
think about a long run
average total cost what would that be
well in the long run we can change the
number of trucks we have and if we can
in the long run we can change the number
of trucks we have we would always be
picking the optimal number of trucks for
the quantity we're producing so in the
long run we would want to be at that
point so if there's only 100 that we
need to produce a day we would only use
one truck if there's 200 produce a day
we would use two trucks and be at that
point if we need to produce 300 we would
have three trucks and be on that point
and so your long run average total cost
curve would be connecting these dots and
so it would look something
it would look something like this and
some of you might be thinking well but
this situation right over here is where
you have one and a half trucks what's
the deal with that but in the long run
you might be able to get a custom truck
size that is one and a half times as big
as your typical truck or two and a half
times as big as your typical truck but
the big takeaway here is that your long
run average total cost curve you can
view as the envelope of all of the
minimum points of all of your various
short run average total cost curve
because at any given for any given
quantity you want to optimize your fixed
cost which puts you at the minimum point
of one of these short run average total
cost curves